le gratin artistique étaient réunis pour
célébrer le meilleur de la musique de
film mais derrière le strass et les
paillettes des festivités se déroulaient
sur fond d'une industrie en crise sur
l'application spotify pour un million d'
écoute j'ai écrit les paroles et la
musique j'ai touché 500 dollars il faut
marteler au gouvernement qu'on veut que
ces grandes compagnies la paie des
impôts et participe à la création de
nouveaux contenus canadiens et en
coulisses ils étaient plusieurs à
partager son mécontentement
je démens chez nous c'est la fin en
terminant j'ai suggéré de réécouter ce
qu'ils disaient à froid demain qu'on
n'oublie pas en deux jours selon eux par
des salaires qu'on répète les mêmes
messages depuis bientôt entre 5 et 10
avec s'est jamais compris c'est sûr que
je trouve que les gouvernements
devraient se mouiller le derrière
depuis des années qu'ils ne l'ont pas
fait alors nous on continue à faire ce
qu'on a à faire mais on souhaite un
moment donné qu' il ya des gens avec du
pouvoir qui puisse au moins se servir de
ce pouvoir là pour défier les
multinationales les ventes d'albums se
sont effondrés et les redevances versées
par les plateformes des côtes en ligne
sont minimes
ils en font de l'argent puis vous voulez
laisser aller avec cet argent là à
l'étranger alors qu'ils font cet argent
le chez nous est posée les demandez leur
de collecter la taxe
et puis fait leur participé à
l'écosystème de la même façon que les
autres joueurs le faut et de l'argent la
plateforme des côtes spotify
en effet cette année elle annoncé
aujourd'hui que ses bénéfices au
troisième trimestre ok de supplique par
rapport à l'an dernier passant de 62 à
349 millions de dollars canadiens les
changements compris entrevoir il va
venir du côté du législatif
si un changement à voir c'est pas dans
l'intérêt quand on est une entreprise
qui fait dans streaming c'est pas dans
son intérêt de redonner de plus d'argent
que nécessaire
durant la campagne électorale le
regroupement des artisans musique avait
fait pression pour que les différents
partis s'engagent sur la question avec
ses coups d'éclat des artistes
souhaitent maintenir la pression pour
que les promesses se transforment en
actes
les libéraux se sont engagées à déposer
un projet de loi au cours de la première
année de leur nouveau mandat ici n'est
dit alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal